so governor sisolak weighed in on the  hiring issues during a small business  roundtable he says  it's a multi-faceted issue he says the  extra benefits unemployment claimants  are receiving may be playing a role for  some  but he thinks there's actually a bigger  issue here one of the problems that  exists is that the minimum wage was held  way too low for way too  long and uh people were just not making  enough money  and that now some of the businesses are  recognizing coming out  and i'm hearing this from a lot of the  restaurant bar owners it's not the tip  jobs that they're having a problem with  it's the non-tip jobs  syselec says the discussion on how to  address the hiring problem is ongoing  from child care to funding they're  looking to overcome the hurdles people  are facing when going back  to work